Rodrigo told me
he had this new script.
And then I was
slightly blown away
by the actual script itself
'cause it's a really
interesting story.
Really?
The cheapest man
who ever lived.
It's as old as time,
the stories of fathers and sons.
The brothers are here
very reluctantly.
They are half brothers.
They both share this father
and he was a terrible
father to them.
They haven't
even seen him in years
and they hear that his
last wish is that they
dig his grave.
And then, you are to
lower the casket
and cover the grave again.
What?
[director]
And action!
Ethan and I...
I always thought
that we would
end up
in a movie together
but it's taken like
30 years for that to happen.
So it was lovely to
finally get a chance
to work together to--
throw ourselves into
these incredible scenes.
His last wish was that his
sons attend his funeral.
You don't have to go.
He's dead.
He'll never know.
You are a very tender man,
you know that?
The humor
and vulnerability
of these brothers
it really moved me.
Hi.
How did you know our father?
We were lovers for awhile.
[director]
Action.
This film explores
human nature.
That's why it hits you
in such a deep way.
It's moving and true,
and very funny.
What was he like as a father?
The worst.
Your father's wish was
to be buried naked.
Why is he faced down?
It's what he requested.
I got it.
The best movies
start at the end.
You know as you're
walking out of the theater
when a movie starts
vibrating inside your head
with how it relates
to your own life.
I hope it's a movie
that rings that bell
that sounds long after
it's been rung.
- Pull over!
- I like you and--
- Whoa, whoa.
- Hey!
♪♪